es bastante tenso y es que en redes
sociales había circulado la versión de
que simpatizantes de trump se iban a
reunir hoy nuevamente en la capital para
llevar a cabo una marcha armada sin
embargo el centro de la ciudad y las
inmediaciones de los edificios públicos
en washington están completamente
cerrados con tanques con camiones y con
más de 25 hombres de la guardia nacional
custodiando la capital la alcaldesa de
la ciudad se refirió al respecto y dijo
que aunque se siente seguro el centro de
la ciudad ella teme que pueda haber
ataques de simpatizantes de trump en
otros puntos de la ciudad que no están
cercanos a los edificios públicos por
otro lado tanto el bien vi como a
empresas de alquiler de carros están
haciendo doble chequeo de seguridad para
evitar alquilar carros y alquilar
inmuebles a simpatizantes de trump o
terroristas domésticos que vengan a la
ciudad a hacer desmanes
trump a dar a su último evento antes de
salir a la florida en la base aérea
de saint andrews y kamala harris mañana
se despedirá de su puesto en el senado
para poder ejercer como vicepresidenta
de eeuu